good to see you Don how are you what's
going on Conan good to see you man how
are you I'm good I liked it you were
making fun of my hair just before we got
started because it's out of control and
I apologize I mean no no I mean I think
your hair is taking care of all of the
making fun all its own I mean especially
this lick that you have going right now
look at that see that's like a Wi-Fi
antenna right there I'm getting I'm
getting 5g right now look at that look
at that I look like the little girl in a
dr. Seuss cartoon who comes who wakes up
when the Grinch is there you said no you
said you showed me just before the show
like you've been you you went with Wow
look at that braids yeah that's
fantastic
I'm will you help me I would love to
virtually give you some help yeah yeah
yeah I had this done once I was up when
we did a week of shows at the Apollo
Theater some women there I went into
their shop and they braided my hair and
I've never felt pain like that in my
life yes yes I have mad respect for
people that can get good can do that
yeah it gives you a fate like a natural
facelift it just pulls everything up yes
I did look like I was sort of in my late
20s but I was in constant pain so I'm
never doing that again let me ask you
how are you as a person we'll get into
you you have I know 35 things going on
right now different projects you always
do your very busy guy but how are you
doing how's your family
we're good for the most part I mean you
know I'm very fortunate that like I said
you know I live with someone who isn't
sick of me and we gotta have our routine
and you know they're fine our kids have
been out of the house for a year now and
they're all they're living together
actually not too far away so we get to
see them they're like our Kobe partners
and no we go over there and hang out
it's cool it's cool but your kids are
old enough to be living out on their own
yeah they're in their 20s now so even if
they didn't want to go I was like you
gotta go so they're out yeah
my kids are still very young but I made
them leave I just I gave them each well
I gave him each one hundred and twenty
dollars and I said I'll see you in a
month I think that's good parenting
because at times like lest you kick them
out of the nest and make them fend for
themselves like any good day yes I
thought it was tough love I've had some
people say you could have given them
more than 120 each and they seemed
pretty young I don't I don't think
people should tell me how to run my life
I when I woke up we still lived in
America right this is thank you thank
you thank you finally someone who gets
it